yeah get into what it means to be a
supporting player
in the mcu particularly scheduling wise
because you kind of got at this
already so jump on for your first your
first film you sign a multi-film
contract and then
i guess what happens from there is it a
situation
where like you sign and you're kind of
just sitting there
waiting until they call you in or do you
know right out the gate at least
a general road map for when and where
they'll need you
ultron was pretty i remember that being
pretty specific
we had a film in italy and then i had
some time off
and that was when i think i did press
for godzilla and then press for godzilla
ended in london and then i had to move
to london
and so i remember having a little chunk
of time off in between
um finishing the film in london but yeah
i mean i was for age of ultron i was in
london for five months and
um definitely didn't film all of it but
i loved living in london so i really
didn't care but that was
during that time was a job i would have
loved to have gotten to do but they
needed me there for the full six weeks
of this other job and it just
its first position you know they they
that's what they pay you for your time
and so to me you just wrap your head
around
you know this they are this is they pay
for your time
um they pay for your time to do press
they pay for your you know it's not just
the actual days on set and i
um because i'm so happy working for them
it doesn't feel like it's um taking
something away from me
marvel is a really um
lovely company to work for i
i don't think any of us can complain
about how how they treat us
i get that sense how about just from a
material script perspective
i don't know how top secret everything
is from your angle of it but
when you hear that you need to be
involved in a future film
is it a situation where you start you
only get your material or do you get the
full script right away and really know
where wanda is going to fall in the
story
well i don't think i ever got an endgame
script i think i just like showed up on
set and i was like
what's the previz battle you know and
then i got
i got i think you know some some pages
for
the the very very end of the movie
infinity war
i got only my part of um
infinity war which felt like half the
movie you know the things that affected
me
so i had no idea what was happening with
everyone else it was just kind of
explained
um and then with one division we had all
of the scripts before we started
tangible and it was just so nice to be
able to you know plot your course
um but yeah there's a lot of secrecy
um but they give you as much as you need
uh like i didn't think i needed all of
infinity like like
everything else that was happening like
didn't really matter to what i
needed to know what to do
you